ela ainda quer mas não só com tamanha
que ela não precisa fazer o que mais
sabe porquê porque vou dormir hoje é
outra vez para isso não falava a título
hoje vou evitar o pessoal aqui de casa é
chato de sua linda agora que você já tem
sua túnica e uma iguana de plástico você
já sabendo que eu vou usar nevo captar
água no domingo e vou colocar este ícone
posso ficar e vamos ver a reação deu
mais coisas mas ficou meio estranho eu
descobri ontem que o ronaldo também tem
muito mediana é e que mais olha só vocês
lembram seguida spray cocheira cocó
muito com o pessoal eu nem pois já tinha
me colocou o que eu acho que já tenho
aqui tudo pronto mas há um pequeno
problema muito do pessoal ainda para
lançar outros estão a dormir portanto
tem que ficar à espera de deus né o
problema de sempre o primeiro a acordar
época tem que ir pra sempre que as
outras pessoas agora têm demonstrado que
algumas manobras por aí andando muito
rápido vai lançar um desafio ao maluco é
que vamos ter que fazer este percurso no
mínimo de tempo possível até que a venda
do caso e vamos começar aqui desta preto
tem que ir votar 321 vai
ai ai ai 3.14 foi cantor só quer pessoal
quer por segundo agora vamos ver como é
capaz de fazer 321 vai 12
não eu vou fazer outra vez
nessa por deixar pra deixar consumir o
máximo pessoal somente o campeão aqui
nessa ou eu é que vou lançar um desafio
é fazer assim para treinar mas só se for
em nova york no canal subscrevam porque
é muito importante mesmo vamos tentar
chegar aos 3 milhões de inscritos que
não esqueçam a tv e cinema porque assim
recebem todas as notificações que
estarei aqui deste conteúdo desse 16 lá
e que neste vídeo e pode ser que eu faço
como irritar a namorada dois muito em
breve não se chamasse o desafio da alza
sua primeira fase ruim do eu vou lá o
quarto dele vou substituir a iguana real
deu presta igualmente poste e vamos ver
a reação deu condição ruim nem vazão
ajuda meio do beijo muito louca se fosse
comigo nem combinado qualquer comida
não conseguia ficar que fique no canto
explica muito ainda estou aqui quem se
tem quando ficou em pedra no assunto o
que percebo por aí e eu aí pessoal ela
não tem medo do atacama
o outro missão cumprida ainda só de
entrar dentro do quarto caso e você só
tá cheio de cocô na camisa dele e vamos
ver o que acendeu um vídeo funciona
agora estamos na mesma câmera tira muito
mal o corpo por tudo
é só você vai embora vigor para o caso é
muito desigual para ter uma porta e
bateu à porta e deu a volta e olha aí
sim como é que se chama de casa por uma
porta que já foi o texto mesmo olha é
isso
até mesmo a china muito com vocês não
têm noção muito a cair próximo a michael
só o que eu vou fazer então controlar o
ppi mesmo vou fazer um buraco que nesta
garrafa vou deixar lá na cozinha porque
cecup pdt sempre toda a água aqui da
casa toda então o que eu vou fazer é ir
pra cozinha chamá lo e vai ter lá
embaixo eu finjo que gritou pedindo
ajuda assim eu quando vir água eu sei
que é impossível logo primeiro impulso
vai servir água e e com certeza vamos
fazer um texto assim que eu for me ver
ou água vai querer também recebeu o ok
agora vamos fechar a escola na cozinha
vão chamar o pe
eu vou deixar que me ouvir
em 18 jogos aqui o vídeo
sei que temos nesse não foi meu problema
é que eu já fico me levou um peso pesado
seja pesado de carbono e tua mãe na
costa da namíbia costa o que fazer vídeo
aqui
ronaldo anos eo mandar uma bomba para
varanda do antigo vai aceitar eu acho
que não saí eu fique em baixa na bomba
vai tentar entrar dentro do quarto antes
de jogar mesmo muitos níquel mas a porta
só eu deixo aqui já mandou a bomba
o que acho que você tenha na caixa ou no
caixa mesmo não pode você tem que avisar
meus pais ainda no quarto num pavilhão
que ele supostamente irritado antaq tem
outra pessoa mas é óbvio que já sabe é
off rush caiu do outro lado ronaldo com
estranhas pararem e pensarem muito
assustadora olha sou e bela bem
informando que ela fica tipo olha aí com
ele só apareceu no caminho rumo ao
comentário aqui dentro do quarto aranha
vai cair olha que sou um crítico já está
pronto agora é só chamar ronaldo espera
que o pastor ronaldo vai entrar no
quarto da casa para aqui fazer uma coisa
daí é isso aqui né e sabe que eu tenho
medo de areia porque sabia
[Aplausos]
tirou o bom futebol que ganha pra isso
aí é só ficar num evento em que vou
fazer mas um giro que está fazendo em
baixo
[Música]
só agora uma idéia um talento e uma
mandíbula e mandar um balde d'água fria
meu futebol já tenho preciso que davi
gil está muito do jeito que está daqui
deste vídeo pelo menos consegui
controlar todo o pessoal aqui da casa eu
acho que sou um meia que ficou irritado
mesmo quem está preocupar com algo que é
muito mal e só sabem vocês acharam os 3
milhões de inscritos
inscreva se aqui em baixo a tmn para
receberem todas as notificações e deixem
muito líquido neste vídeo pessoal a
serviço da imensa que o canal e também
podem vir aqui em baixo os dois vídeos
anteriores e aqui do lado vocês podem se
inscrever aqui no canal tarde e só
fiquem bem até aproximar